I've gotten that joke you were playing
as fetch here I see I am playing as
fetch here this is uh oh my goodness you
just lighting up that parked car Oh take
this people part calmly in your car oh I
guess they were so that's how you stop
it stop a drive-by is you'd kill
everybody in the area drive-by done
there's no drive-by here just a bunch of
terribly burned bodies that's right so
this is post you're welcome Seattle this
is post story here okay and I'm glad I
get to play this now because because as
bad as I was at lickin bottom Majah the
good news with this is infamous first
light is so incredibly easy that now I
can look amazing wasn't second Sun easy
as well though is yes easier this is
easier in my opinion so this is a
standalone expansion right yes it's like
it's kind of like what Far Cry Blood
Dragon wants the Far Cry so you don't
necessarily need to own well you don't
need to own and from a second son to
play this but that you're playing as
fetch II was a character that you meet
in the in the the main game what what's
going on here what so what's new what's
different we just talking more of the
same that ball she's got she's got her
own upgrade system oops wrong button
sorry
by pressing the stand in one place for
us a touchpad there we go cool it
doesn't like any of my button presses
what is going on oh well so yes she's
got holy nyan powers oh you got mom okay
so an infamous Elvis you could you had
your default pair of the stars she don't
want who who teaches Delson teaches is
power
wrong word well yeah she's dean of
boomers oh do you see look from Stila
firmer right straight up robble robble
joint i think so you hate you hamburger
lit from her heaven doesn't care kevin's
goose or Hamburglar from her but in here
this is all her stuff so so it starts
with you know like a little bit of her
backstory and and her brother and it's
interesting because part of part of how
they they deal with the story is a
little bit different from how it was
described in second oh really so it
there's a little bit less of the I'm a
you know I'm a drug dealer or I'm a
druggie out for revenge kind of thing
and they try to give it some
our contacts make her a little more
humanized I guess okay
well outside of the story because
infamous is a very mechanic it was a
very videogame ass video it is a video
game II video game so is this very video
game II - are you very video gaming you
show me your map
show me how video game it is okay
because infamous is what I like the
benefi miss as well but it's you know
basically the entire game is you were
just going from just district to
district and video liberation crap out
of so yeah that's what it is except here
this is post game I've done all of the
side things so this stuff is just stuff
that appear so is it similar are they
were they were you taking down those big
and yeah it's similar but it's very it's
much more limited than in second son
like you only you stop the drive-bys you
rescue some hostages if you want you you
collect shards by doing the whole like
you'll see like when I when I now go
into light speed now you've got these
little you know like for Texas to go
through he's basically intervals on the
ground yeah Mario Kart exactly exactly
right but the other the other big thing
is the is the challenge arenas okay and
I'll go into a challenge arena you want
to show you what that's about so I'll do
survival so you get to play if you've
already finished if you've already
played second son then you get access to
using Delson and these as well okay so
if you don't know in second son so if
you don't know if you don't know second
son that you don't get access to Delson
but that's not a huge deal but there's
it's interesting here so this is this is
sort of the battle you know this is the
battle arena this is this a wave based
it is wave based what do you think it
was he said it was survival you know and
there's another one where you also have
to hoping where you also have to rescue
hostages okay Kevin sound the
unimplemented first life because right
now it seems like it's pretty little bit
it's pretty limited all things
considered the one the one thing that I
liked at first was the challenge stuff
because you're like you're moving around
you're doing cool stuff you you know you
get to you know you get to shoot guys
and then you have cool enemies in the in
the arenas when they start coming out
that are all demonic
cool okay like flying things and and
stuff like that but then after a while
what you discover is is that once you
unlock fully unlock your I'll show you
I'm sure they're gonna try to get to a
good spot once you fully unlock your
homing missiles yeah AUP detainee it
adjust yes I do it's just easy mode
that's like saying I I really wanna
MoBay and all I got was this t-shirt
well you're you're right now yes like
that the prison system is given out
hoodies and no it's like some button-up
jackets branded slave hoodies but that's
the thing right now that's how this game
is set up is that you are you are
showing off your powers to till what's
her face and as evil okay boilers green
maiden that's how you kill her again I
assume so so that's what's happening
like the whole the story itself is told
as a flashback oh like you've already
been captured for the most part then
stuff happens after that but you know
you're telling the story is a flashback
and all of these challenge levels are
done narrative Lee in a way where you're
you're showing off what you can do okay
at Chris did you play in from a second
stone I played a bit of infamous second
son why did you stop here we go I was
just really I don't know my my sort of
enthusiasm for open-world run around and
do all these objective stuffs is sort of
been on on Wayne lately there's like I
tried to get in a black flag last year I
did a little bit but it didn't quite
catch for me I don't really know I don't
know why yeah just you know you get
these like different sort of phases in
your life with your gaming at least I do
where I like have an appetite for a
certain kind of game and like now I'm
really into like playing some
civilization again yeah like you know
not not so much the open-world stuff but
yeah I don't know I did get to interview
the voice actress at e3 who plays a
fetch Laura Bailey she's great she's
also super prolific it's like the voice
of chun-li Ojeda in all modern Street
Fighter games she was in she was like
lady Comstock and BioShock Infinite
she's a big character in DBZ like it
tons of anime I so yeah I mean I I got
to play around with it it was kind of
fun but it just
the combat didn't really click with me
in terms of like this is really really
satisfying this is something that I get
inherent pleasure from I think I really
got I feel the exact same way about when
I play Black Flag and I think the reason
I got into this is that I was sick for
like three or four days and I needed
something to just sponge into yeah and
this was this was perfect that I was
about to say the headshot stuff was the
thing that got me into the combat in
this game
slow down slow down and you see the are
spamming you know I thought you know
there's a bit of skill involved in it as
opposed to like or like when you're
doing the bits on the legs when you
throw the the the grenades like the
powers you unlocked and stuff for you
know varied in a way to at least kept
you I feel like it was distracting me a
lot like at the Capitol every time I get
a little bored I don't like a new power
and then I'm just I'm not worried around
with yeah yeah this you played you've
completed second yeah completed second
son what you got on this are you
reviewing this I did it's up now I you
know I I I'll check it up it's okay I
gave it a 6 ok it's it's okay but I gosh
darn it there we go
but like you'll see like I don't mind
necessarily that a game is easy but what
kills me about this is like this is a
chat this is a challenge level right so
you sort of expect that there's a reason
to go but you can easily once you
upgrade your homing missile thing in
particular you can easily sleepwalk your
way through this to Diamond level and
far beyond like there I got to the point
where I just stopped playing certain
challenges because I would I would have
3 million points and I would be well
past I would be 45 minutes in yeah and I
you know it's just like okay I'm 45
minutes in and it's still really easy
and so I mean it gets harder obviously
but I just got to the point where it's
like this is getting tedious I can do
this one spammy technique and so
therefore I don't know I don't feel like
if I'm comparing myself on the
leaderboards which you can do it just
sort of felt like that there's it's not
really a meaning meaningful comparison
to me because I don't feel like we're
comparing how good we are I feel like
we're comparing how quickly we learned
that you can spam brushing techniques
okay how much time you
willing to spend continuing to do it
yeah totally
add the story stuff how long is that did
you spend like this just do story
probably two hours oh wow okay maybe oh
$15 so get me stand alone I could be
wrong somebody correct me if I'm wrong
they will that's what the internet is
for correcting our work our shoddy work
but I mean I like it well enough I just
think that in all things listener
there's no morality system somebody said
to be on on on Twitter this morning well
of course there's no morality system
she's she's out on a revenge quest to
you know be mad at drug das that that
ruined her and her relationship with her
brother that's pretty much life but they
actually retcon the story a little bit
to the point where it's you don't have a
brother and she doesn't well know she
still has a brother bill on drugs and
drugs are great the circum the
circumstances of Howard's death yeah as
described in second son or are
differently described shown here it's
weird because she got her powers from a
crystal meth addiction that's the whole
story
well they don't they don't crop they
don't get rid of it I mean that thanks
so much Matt Dory is such a superhuman
sorry is if you take meth you too can be
a superhero
not even once but if you do it once
maybe do it like a million times because
then you'll least have superpowers there
you go I'm gonna do see you later nobody
listen to what we're saying we're
terrible terrible people
alright 6.0 on gamespot calm kevin fine
art i think we are done with infamous
second son first life do a singularity
I'm doing one of our Dingle Lera T boom
and there's oh sweet Lera T I like how
the singularity knows only to pull in
the guys that are bad and now you yeah
and now you for the met or just anything
else measure body 20% like it knows
what's bad yeah yeah all right Kevin
words thank you very much Carlo always I
love being from a second son first life
after playing and listen Bobby yeah
we're sucking at bottle Majah
another review for bottle made you be up
again I don't know because I'm still
playing it but I'm hoping in the next
couple days
cool awesome